المشاهدين الى تطورات ملفي حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت السلطات الطوارئ في
بريان سكار الروسيه عن تعرض منطقه كليموس
كافيه المقاطعه لهجوم بعشر مسيرات واشارت
السلطات الى انه تم اسقاط عدد من هذه
المسيرات فيما تم اسقاط البقيه بواسطه
محطات الرادار الالكترونيه واكدت السلطات
على ان هذا الهجوم لم يتسبب باي اضرار
ماديه او بشريه يتزامن مع ذلك اعلنت سلطات
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قامت باطلاق النار
على نقطه تفتيش حدوديه في مقاطعه بريانسك
واوضحت السلطات ان الهجوم طال حجز بوروجا
الحدودي لعبور السيارات كذلك اعلنت سلطات
الطوارئ في اقليم كاراسم عن سقوط مسيره
اوكرانيه صباح اليوم في منشاه ال س كي
لتقرير النفط غرب مدينه كاراس نودار دون
ان تلحق اضرارا او خسائر وكان حاكم واقليم
كراس ندار الروسي بنيامينكو
اعلن ان حريقا نشب في مصفاه افيسكي لتكرير
النفط في الاقليم نتيجه هجوم بمسيره
اوكرانيه وافاد الحاكم عبر تيليجرام انه
تمت السيطره على الحريق واخماده بالفعل
مشيرا الى انه لم تسجل اي اصابات يشار لنا
روسيا واوكرانيا تستخدم المسيرات فيها
هجماتها المتبادله في الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا المستمره منذ اكثر من 15 شهرا
في غضون ذلك نقلت وكاله توتاس الروسيه عن
مركز الاستجابه للازمات في منطقه بلغرود
جنوب غرب روسيا قوله ان القوات الاوكرانيه
قصفت مدينه
شبيكينو الواقعه في منطقه بلغرود مما اسفر
عن اصابه اربعه اشخاص اضاف المركز في بيان
ادى المبانيه السكنيه تضررت واشتعلت
النيران في عدد من المركبات يذكر ان منطقه
شبيكينو الواقعه على الحدود مع اوكرانيا
تعرضت لنيران اوكرانيا كثيفه خلال الايام
الماضيه حيث سقطت يوم الاثنين وحده
155 قذيفه على اراضيها
افدى موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي انه نتيجه
قصف الروسي استهدف منشات بحريه اوكرانيه
في مدينه اوديسا الواقعه جنوب غرب
اوكرانيا اصيبت سفينه الانزال الاوكرانيه
يوري اليفرينكو اصابات مباشره ما ادى الى
غرقها وقال الموقع ان حريقا اندلع في
السفينه بسبب الاستهداف مما ادى الى
انفجار الذخيره على متنها وغرقها اشييرا
الى وقوع خسائر في طاقم السفينه
في المقابل اعلى انا حاكم ودونيتسكي
الاوكراني عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى في هجوم
الروسي على دونيتس ولوغانسك بدوره قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
ما وصفها بعملياتها الدفاعيه على جبهتي
خرسون
جنوبيه البلاد اضاف ان الروس نفذوا خلال
اليوم الماضي 64 ضربه جويه و88 رشقه
صاروخيه على طول خطوط تماس في المقابل اكد
الجيش الاوكراني ان قوته نفذت خلال
الساعات الماضيه احدى عشره غاره على مواقع
القوات الروسيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وقال ان مدفعيته استهدفت نقاط تحكم ووحدات
المدفعيه ومستودعات وقود للقوات الروسيه
انا من بدايه ضعنا في اخر المستجدات
الميدانيه وايضا المواقف الاوكرانيه اخر
المواقف خصوصا تلك المتعلقه باعلان الرئيس
الشيشاني بتلقيه اوامر بدء هجوم على خرسون
هل هناك موقف اوكراني حول هذا القرار
نعم حتى هذه اللحظه سهام لموقف اوكرانيا
رسمي من هذه المساله لا يوجد تعليق من
الحكومه او الرئاسه الاوكرانيه او القوات
الاوكرانيه سوى ان المناطق التي يتحدث
عنها الرئيس الشيشاني هي المناطق
المستهدفه على الارجح بالهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني الذي يعني دار حوله الكثير من
الغلط والجدل فيما يخص الموعد الخاص به
هناك من المسؤولين الاوكران من قالوا بان
هذا الهجوم يحتاج الى مزيد من الوقت من
قال بان هذا الهجوم بدا بالفعل ومن تحدث
عن الجاهزيه الاوكرانيه جاهزيه القوات
الاوكرانيه لبدء هذا الهجوم لا سيما في
المناطق الجنوبيه الحديث عن خيرسون
القريبه من هنا من نيكولايت الحديث عن
زبروج ايضا او المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه في ريف زبالوجا الجنوب
الجنوبي الحديث عن ميليتوبل وتكماك
والعديد من المناطق هناك لكن اسمحي لي ان
ابدا باخر التطورات المتعلقه المواقف
السياسيه في الحقيقه خلال الدقائق الاخيره
على التلفزيون والبث الوطني الاوكراني كان
هنالك تصريحا لافتا للمستشار في الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بدولياك الذي قال بشكل
واضح بان وعلق بشكل واضح على الهجوم الذي
تعرضت له العاصمه الروسيه يوم امس قال بان
وصول الحرب الى الداخل الروسي هي نتيجه
طبيعيه لما سماه العدوان على اوكرانيا من
قبل روسيا وقال بان على الجميع ان يلتقط
الاشارات جيدا فيما يخص التطورات في اقاله
بان في بيجرود العمليات متواصله وصفها
بالمتواصله
لقوات الروسيه المعارضه للكرملين الحديث
هنا عن فيلق حريه روسيا بالاضافه الى فريق
المتطوعين الروس وقال بان هذه العمليات لم
تعد تقتصر على الاطراف وانما بدات بالتوسع
وتحدث عن الهجوم الذي استهدف موسكو يوم
امس وقال بان مثل هذه العمليات تدخل الى
العمق الروسي تدريجيا وهذا الحديث في
الحقيقه لافت في ظل النفي الاوكراني
المتكرر عن انها لا توجه نيرانها الى داخل
الاراضي الروسيه هل نحن امام سيناريو جديد
امام روايات قد تبدا بالتدحرج شيئا فشيئا
وصولا الى الاعلان الجانب الاوكراني عن
تبنيه للعمليات في العمق الروسي وهو اشار
ايضا الى ما سماها بالمنشات الحساسه
استهداف المنشات الحساسه الروسيه والبنيه
التحتيه ومستودعات النفط واستهداف هذه
المنشات تكررت طيله الايام الماضيه واليوم
ايضا لا سيما في المناطق الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا والحديث عن شبه جزيره القرم لا
يتوقف ولا ينتهي في غضوء كل ذلك تواصل
القصف الروسي نهايه سهام وفقا للادارات
العسكريه على المناطق الجنوبيه وتحدثت
السلطات لاسيما قياده عمليات الجنوب عن
تحركات وصفتهم بالمريبه للقوات الروسيه في
البحر الاسود
الجزيره شكرا